porque ante la mentira cuando más alta
tenemos que tener la guardia muchas
veces le bajamos ese mensaje de whatsapp
que podemos reenviar sin revisar
demasiado puede cambiar vidas para
siempre
las facebook o noticias falsas no son un
fenómeno nuevo aunque parezca
sorprendente tiene más de 150 años
muchos consideran el gran engaño de la
luna la primera noticia falsa publicada
en un medio de comunicación en agosto de
1835 el periódico neoyorquino the sun
publicó una serie de seis artículos con
ilustraciones en los que informaba
acerca del descubrimiento de vida en la
luna incluyendo seres mitológicos en
teoría el artículo estaba basado en la
investigación del astrónomo john
herschel quien no sabía acerca de la
publicación y firmado por andrew gran
una persona inexistente
para tener un poquito de contexto de
sant estuvo más de 100 años en el
mercado y junto con the new york times y
el new herald tribune eran los tres
periódicos con más circulación en nueva
york en esa época y de hecho era
considerado el más conservador de los
tres en cuanto a noticias falsas nadie
es infalible
pero en la edad pre redes sociales
seguramente la noticia falsa que quedó
más en el inconsciente popular no estaba
diseñado para hacer una noticia falsa
pero estuvo tan bien hecha e iba tan de
lleno a las emociones de la audiencia
que genera un fenómeno similar
en octubre de 1938 orson welles y su
equipo de radio emiten un capítulo que
titula la guerra de los mundos' en el
cual dramatizan la invasión
extraterrestre a la tierra el capítulo y
la puesta en escena si bien estado pre
anunciada fue tan realista e iba tan
directo a los sentimientos de una
sociedad que ya los tenía a flor de piel
que genera un pánico enorme
los sentimientos cuando se trata de
noticias falsas pueden jugarnos una muy
mala pasada
las redes sociales llegaron para
cambiarlo todo en materia de información
la noticia que antes viajaba varias
horas en un camión de reparto para
llegar a nuestras manos hoy por el viaje
microsegundos el internet
y a manera de ejemplo según un estudio
de pew research uno de cada cinco
adultos en los eeuu se informa
principalmente por las redes sociales y
no son los bots los causantes de las
crecientes pequeños según nuestro
estudio en este caso el mighty y ya se
van a decir cuando alguien quiere
defender un punto siempre sacó un
estudio una universidad conocida pero le
juro que en este caso es cierto
las noticias falsas viajan en la red más
rápido transmitida por humanos que por
bots y una noticia falsa viaja en la red
seis veces más rápido que una verdadera
en el 2016 se me presenta una de esas
oportunidades que van moldeando tu vida
el ir a vivir a estados unidos- hacer un
máster hermanas me en la universidad
stanford en california eeuu que con su
primera enmienda es considerado una cuna
de la libertad de expresión
y la posibilidad venía acompañada con
ser testigo de primera mano de las
elecciones presidenciales del 2016 que
son consideradas históricas no sólo para
eeuu para el mundo por un rol que nunca
antes tuvieron las redes sociales
soy un usuario activo en las redes
sociales considero que el pri no hay un
medio de comunicación más efectivo por
alcance llegada e inmediatez nada a joel
por el comparable en los primeros días
allí empecé a experimentar fenómenos
interesantes veía en mi red medios que
no veía en méxico
y dije bueno por la geolocalización
estoy expuesto otro tipo de medios pero
las cosas interesantes siguieron pasando
parecía que por ejemplo mi coterráneo el
papá francisco estaba recomendando votar
por donald trump increíble pero no
solamente increíble falso y los sucesos
continuaron hillary clinton vendiéndole
armas análisis
o una red de pederastia en una cadena de
pizzerías que inclusive llegó una
persona entra armada una de ellas y no
había el lado político noticias falsas
había de ambos lados era simple y
sencillamente una nueva dinámica
como dato curioso según un estudio de
paz sumo entre agosto del 2016 y el día
de las elecciones en eeuu en 2016 los
posts de facebook que tenían información
falsa tuvieron más interacciones
comentarios compartieron me gusta que
los que tenían información verdadera 8
puntos 7 millones versus 7 puntos 3
millones el resto de la historia es
materia conocida
en el 2017 cuando regresamos a mexico
empezamos a ver un fenómeno similar aquí
en un creciente número de noticias
falsas y los grupos de whatsapp que se
hacen más y más numeroso un par de meses
luego de llegar a suceder lamentable
terremoto de septiembre 2017
a las horas de que suceda empiezo a
recibir como mucho a ustedes la noticia
de que la onu estaba pronosticando a
otro terremoto en más de 10 grados en la
escala richter lo habré recibido más de
10 veces en el término de dos horas a
todo el que me la mandó le respondí cual
ya las fuentes todos me respondieron la
onu y en a todos les respondí pero yo me
metí en la página de la onu y no hay
nada siempre del otro lado encontré el
silencio de radio
el impacto fue tal que en la onu tú que
públicamente salir a desmentirlo la ola
de la fei news nos estaba alcanzando en
mexico y no estábamos preparados y ni
hablar con la pandemia ahora resulta que
las redes 5g son causantes del virus o
que bill gates tenía planeado
insertarnos un microchip con la vacuna
acá me parece un buen momento para parar
el balón y aclarar que ninguna de la
noticia de las que hablé hasta ahora
están basada en hechos verdaderos a
excepción por supuesto de la desmentida
de la onu pero porque todos y digo todos
en algún momento caemos o caemos en unos
sueños en una noticia falsa mucho de la
explicación está acá
las noticias falsas están diseñadas para
generar reacción porque porque las
reacciones generan emociones las
emociones generan impulsos y los
impulsos nos empujan a actuar a
alimentar el algoritmo de las redes
sociales sin revisar demasiado qué hay
detrás del título o la fuente de lo que
estamos compartiendo como lo explica de
una manera muy simple y sencilla el
libro inteligencia emocional 2.0 lo que
percibimos los estímulos próximos a
través de los sentidos ingresan al
cerebro por el sistema límbico que donde
sentimos las emociones y luego pasan al
sistema racional que donde procesamos la
información si lo que recibimos ya en
esta instancia viene prejuzgado o pre
filtrado por nuestras emociones poco va
a poder hacer nuestra parte analítica es
por eso que las noticias falsas apelan a
emociones fuertes
y si nuestro sereno ya es un juicio de
valor muchas veces es difícil dar la
vuelta a la página atrás sobre todo si
fue bombardeado repetidamente con
mensajes similares y para muestra basta
un botón
una pregunta rápida que seguramente los
fan de star wars me la van a poder
responder mucho más rápido de qué color
es y tryp yo
hasta que los escuché gritar dorado
bueno la verdad es que esa respuesta es
incorrecta si trip yo tenía una pierna
plateada pero qué pasó acá
nuestro ser ya nos recibió a lo largo
del tiempo diferentes estímulos varios
de ellos incompletos completo en la
película la asumió como cierta y nunca
más volvió a revisarla se conoce como
efecto mandela y lo mismo pasa con la fe
y nos cuando alguien quiere que algo se
quede nuestro cerebro nos ven bombardea
repetidamente con mensajes similares
de las prioridades que están más alta en
la pirámide de maslow una es el
reconocimiento social y una de las
principales formas de sobresalir es el
portador de una novedad
él formó off y los missing out las ganas
de ser primero compartió una primicia
una noticia de primera mano muchas veces
nos empujan a compartir sin revisar
demasiado lo que estamos compartiendo
es por eso que las noticias falsas
apelan a hacernos sentir portadores de
algo que nadie más tiene
todos vemos el mundo a través de nuestro
bagaje nuestras experiencias nuestro
pasado las arrugas de la palma de
nuestra mano y vemos la realidad a
través de ese marco muchas veces
incompleta es natural a todos nos pasa
solamente tenemos que saber aceptando
entenderlo y ampliar ese marco
se conoce como sesgo cognitivo las
noticias falsas están diseñadas para
agarrarnos con la guardia baja porque
confirman un miedo o creencia que
nosotros tenemos de antemano
ahora mucho se ha hablado en la pandemia
de detener la propagación las noticias
falsas son como un virus con que somos
logremos que una persona la detecte
no la comparta la reporte estamos
salvando del contagio a muchos que
vienen detrás
los gigantes de las redes sociales ya
están empezando a ser parte de su parte
podemos decir facebook anuncio en sus
últimos reportes trimestrales de
transparencia que ha eliminado en
promedio por trimestre en el 2020 de los
primeros trimestres 1600 millones de
cuentas falsas un 20 por ciento de la
población mundial por trimestre y otros
1.600 millones de publicaciones spam lo
malo de esto es que más del 99.5 de
estas acciones fueron por iniciativa de
facebook no por reporte de los usuarios
twitter a su vez está empezando a marcar
las publicaciones de personalidades
reconocidas que no están basadas en
hechos confirmados y ni donald trump se
salvó también ha surgido en este último
tiempo o páginas o herramientas que
envían alertas de noticias falsas a
través de un reporte estructurado de
revisión
pero no tenemos que necesitar de
guardianes en nuestro viaje digital por
la información no podemos tercerizar esa
responsabilidad nadie nos la va a
subsidiar
el momento de parar este fenómeno es
momento tomar un rol activo un rol de
protagonistas de esta historia es
momento de ser embajadores de la verdad
y hablando de historias déjenme
compartirles una historia
acatlán de osorio puebla
veinte mil habitantes el pueblo vive
principalmente del campo
fundamentalmente el maíz y de las
remesas que envían familiares que
emigran en los eeuu
y carlos flores
21 años
nació en las inmediaciones de acatlán y
se muda a 250 kilómetros al noreste para
estudiar derecho alberto flórez 43 años
casados su tío vive en las inmediaciones
de acatlán y como tantos otros vive del
campo
riccardo regresa al pueblo a visitar a
su familia y junto con alberto su tío
van al centro del pueblo a comprar
materiales para un pozo de cemento que
estaban terminando no ibas seguido al
pueblo un lugar donde todo se conoce
la policía decide detenerlos no por
haber prueba de ningún delito sino por
cierto desorden que se comenzó a armar
cuando algunos habitantes los abordaron
ya en el patrullero y de camino a la
comisaría más habitantes los comienzan a
abordar y les comienzan a gritar
secuestradores y asesinos de niños
no iban seguido al pueblo no los
conocían estaban cerca de la escuela la
gente y sus miedo los transformó en
aquellos secuestradores asesino de niños
de los que alertaba un mensaje falso de
whatsapp que estaba circulando
o sea en la comisaría y alentado por
algunos falsos líderes que a veces
existen las emociones comienzan a subir
ya subir más gente se congrega inclusive
empieza a transmitir en vivo por
facebook
la situación llega un punto tal que
tiran abajo las puertas de la comisaría
sacan a ricardo y alberto los comienzan
a golpear muy fuertemente les echan
combustible los prenden fuego y
lamentablemente ambos fallecen
maría la madre de ricardo una de las
tantas inmigrantes en los eeuu vio en
vivo en facebook cómo mataban a su hijo
su mensaje en la transmisión pidiendo
compasión y que se detengan nada pudo
evitar lamentablemente lo mismo pasó con
jazmín la joven esposa de alberto
la peor consecuencia de una noticia
falsa se hace presente una tragedia y en
este caso la muerte
pero no tenemos que llegar a este punto
ni a ningún otro punto
este fenómeno esta curva nosotros la
podemos aplanar y con herramientas
simples sencillos y propias
la voluntad de acción colectiva en este
tema es fundamental y como muchas otras
cosas en la vida no deja de ser la
resultante de una fórmula la resultante
de la razón que tanto investigamos qué
tanto interactuamos que tanto reportamos
y qué tan abierto entramos al diálogo
ahora cómo aplicamos en la vida
cotidiana cada término esta fórmula
si algo que estamos leyendo está
atajando de una manera muy fuerte
nuestras emociones
pongamos paño frío debemos del lugar a
nuestra parte de la razón
no actuemos todavía investiguemos una
búsqueda muy básica que nos dé un mejor
marco para tomar una decisión una
búsqueda en google que fotos incluye la
noticia cuál es el autor cuál es la
fuente cosas muy básicas no tenemos que
ser sherlock holmes solamente controlar
nuestro fondo y darnos ese te invito y
es fácil si alguien nos pregunta cuál es
la fuente lo podemos responder de una
manera segura
no interactuamos cualquier interacción a
una noticia que no tenemos válida de
verdad compartir un me gusta un
comentario alimenta el algoritmo de las
redes sociales y le da más visibilidad a
una noticia que potencialmente puede
llegar a ser falsa protejamos a los
cerillos que vienen después que nosotros
reportemos queremos ver ese 99 de
facebook bajar
porque más usuarios reportan
es un medio y con dos un minimalismo
aplicado a nuestra exposición a las
noticias falsas
y por último lo tengamos vergüenza ni de
hablar ni de responder ni de hacer
control de daños si recibimos una
noticia que detectamos que es falsa
avisemos que es falsa a todos
si compartimos o enviamos una noticia
que luego detectamos que es falsa porque
a cualquiera nos puede pasar avisamos
que lo que compartimos es falso a todos
no podemos tercerizar esta
responsabilidad como ciudadanos
llámeme soñador
pero así como nuestra época de inicios
escolares nos enseñaron a buscar en el
diccionario papel se acuerdan de esos
todavía
estoy convencido
que en la época actual es imprescindible
enseñarle a nuestros niños las bases
para discernir entre la verdad y la
mentira aprender y enseñar y de las
mejores formas enseñar es predicar con
el ejemplo en la escuela y en casa nunca
antes un fenómeno de tal magnitud con
consecuencias que pueden ir desde
generar ansiedad
incidir en el destino de un país o ser
el inicio de una tragedia y con un
crecimiento tan exponencial estuvo a 1 2
o 3 clics de que nosotros seamos la
verdadera solución hagamos nuestra parte
[Aplausos]